hays comme un tyran ou adulé comme un
dieu l'ayatollah comédie vient de mourir
à l'âge de 89 ans fondateur de la
république islamique iranienne il avait
entraîné son pays dans une guerre sainte
contre l'occident
pékin la fin de l'espoir l'armée a tiré
sur la foule bilans encore partiels 1400
morts plus de dix mille blessés et
l'ordre n'est toujours pas revenu dans
la capitale chinoise
5ème conférence mondiale sur le sida à
montréal l'afrique est ravagée par cette
maladie à la vitesse d'un feu de forêt à
terme ce sont des populations entières
qui sont menacés de disparition
enquête dans ce journal voilà monsieur
bonsoir pratiquement à la même heure à
l'aube de ce dimanche matin deux coups
de tonnerre ont éclaté dans le monde
à téhéran l'ayatollah comédie venait de
mourir à l'âge de 89 ans après dix ans
d'un pouvoir absolu sur l'iran mais
aussi dix années de croisade islamique
contre le monde occidental
au même moment à pékin les blindés et
les mitrailleuses de l'armée mettait un
terme sanglant à cette semaine d'un
printemps de contestation débuté dans la
joie et la non violence
ces deux événements vont bien entendu
constitué l'essentiel de ce journal en
commençant par la chine après plusieurs
tentatives infructueuses l'armée a donc
finalement dégagé la place tienanmen et
le centre de pékin
le résultat est terrible un premier
bilan partiel fait état de 1400 morts et
de plus de dix mille blessés au brier de
l'est
t'es qu'un n'est plus ce soir qu'une
capitale meurtrier dévastée alors que
les tirs continuaient sur la place
tiananmen qui rassembla pendant cette
semaine les espoirs de liberté de la
jeunesse chinoise la population affolée
compte ses morts étant encore de sauver
les milliers de blessés des combats de
la nuit dernière il était un peu plus de
21h française hier soir quand les
lampadaires qui éclairait la place
tiananmen se sont tout à coup et un
l'armée du gouvernement chinois venait
de lancer la bataille sanglante destinée
à mettre fin à la révolte des étudiants
des étudiants qui espéraient encore une
fois pouvoir fraterniser avec la troupe
dès le début de la soirée de violents
affrontements avaient commencé opposé
les soldats aux milliers d'étudiants
rejoint au centre de la capitale par une
foule en colère qui a longtemps tenté de
contenir les convois militaires aux
portes de la place
pour la première fois depuis
l'instauration de la loi martiale il y a
trois semaines l'armée a tiré dans la
foule
bilan sans doute partiel on parle ce
soir de plus d'un millier de morts
c'est un gouvernement réactionnaire il a
fait tirer sur le peuple il a tué des
milliers d'étudiants dans l'université
très vite les chars se déployer dans la
ville pour nettoyer la place tiananmen
la population prise de panique
cherchant à échapper aux tirs aveugles
des canons l'armée s'en est pris aussi
aux correspondants étrangers témoins de
ces scènes de carnage
alors que la foule tentait de les
protéger
l'un de nos confrères de paris match a
été blessé par balles deux journalistes
de six billets s'arrêter
longtemps apparu débonnaire la révolte
des étudiants chinois prend désormais un
tour tragique favorisant à pékin les
risques d'une véritable guerre civile
il est sûr en tout cas que le
gouvernement de deng xiaoping a commis
une erreur difficilement réparable en
décidant de précipiter la répression
d'un mouvement qui semblait depuis
plusieurs jours déjà condamné à
s'émousser
voilà donc pour cette terrible journée
de dimanche il est actuellement en 3h du
matin à pékin en ligne notre envoyé
spécial bruno le dreff rien n'est encore
vraiment fini à pékin bruno nom daniel
pour l'instant en tous les cas le centre
de la ville et déserts à l'exception
bien sûr des abords de la place
tiananmen était encore il ya quelques
vingt ans j'ai pu voir les chars les
véhicules blindés et les troupes de
l'armée
une armée qui n'est d'ailleurs toujours
pas dégagé les voies d'accès à la place
tienanmen
si la grande avenue qui mène est jonché
de débris de pierres de restes de
barricades des bus incendié j'en ai vu
qui flambaient encore se trouve toujours
en travers de cinq carrefours sur l'un
de ces bus de l'est d'ailleurs fait une
macabre rencontre on a pendu le corps
d'un soldat
elle est née il pilotait un blindé
aurait écrasé onze étudiants avant
d'être arrêtés et tués par la foule
c'est du moins ce que mme affirmé un
habitant du quartier
dans l'après-midi des propos ont pénétré
sur plusieurs campus de pékin et d'après
les témoignages que j'ai pu recueillir
l'occupation se pincerait pour l'instant
sans violence mais le mal être de pékin
provoquer des mouvements de protestation
dans la plupart des grandes villes
chinoises à nanjing une manifestation a
rassemblé plus de cent mille personnes
à shanghai les étudiantes et habité par
icade et les conducteurs de bus sont mis
en grève
des affiches rouges portant le mouvement
en chinois ont également été placardées
sur les murs deux cantons de viana et de
nankin et l'histoire à la télévision
chinoise et vu des images de la place
tiananmen
débarrassé de ses occupants on y
montrait un phare faire basculer la
statue de la démocratie que les
étudiants des beaux-arts de bk avait
édifié mardi dernier vous vous en
souvenez sûrement le commentaire
précisait que des soldats ayant été
agressée puis désarmée par un petit
groupe de bandits c'est le mot qui était
utilisé par le commentateur chinois le
politburo s'était trouvé dans
l'obligation d'ordonner à l'armée de
tirer à lui
oui bruno ratant dernière question at on
entendu ou vu aujourd'hui à la
télévision chinoise un homme politique
un homme de gouvernement justifier ce
qui s'était passé la nuit dernière
non non non la planification c'était que
des groupes de bandits c'est encore une
fois c'est tellement utilisé on était
pris à l'armée qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution que de tirer toute
dernière question et vous l'impression
que d'autres manifestations peuvent
avoir lieu demain dans les jours qui
viennent ou avez-vous vraiment
l'impression que le mouvement l'a été
réprimées avec la violence que l'on sait
et écouter ce que je sais de source sûre
c'est que des groupes d'habitants de
pékin voulait aujourd'hui en tous les
cas dans la soirée ou dans la nuit
tenté d'attaquer les soldats de
tiananmen et ce sont les étudiants les
leaders étudiants qui les auront ils les
ont rencontrés et qui les ont dissuadés
de commettre cette attaque qui pouvait
mener qu'à un nouveau bain de sang
mais la situation est encore très tendu
et j'ai appris dans l'après midi que la
plupart des ambassades dont celles de
france d'ailleurs travail et à des plans
d'évacuation de leurs ressortissants au
cas où la situation s'aggravait encore
merci brute dans le dress mobilisés
pendant toute la durée des événements la
communauté chinoise dispersés dans le
monde à manifester aujourd'hui notamment
à paris anne 15 burget
ils pleurent leurs camarades tombés à
tienanmen couleurs et réclament
vengeance 3000 étudiants chinois de
paris aux cris de vive la liberté vive
les martyrs de la démocratie gerbe de
fleurs blanches traditionnelles et
brassards noirs signe du deuil
parmi les banderoles un large tissu
blanc marqué à l'encré rouge
la honte affiché à la couleur du sang
qui a coulé hong kong
cinq cent mille manifestants avaient cet
après-midi choisi le stade de vaty
vallée on y projetait le massacre de
tiananmen sur écran géant
hong kong en clame britannique qui doit
revenir sous souveraineté chinoise en
les chinois du territoire ont juré de
lutter jusqu'à la mort contre le régime
de pékin réaction encore celle des
principaux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dans le monde le président
américain george bush condamne cette
intervention armée et déclare qu'elle
risque d'affecter les relations entre
les etats-unis et la chine madame
thatcher premier ministre britannique
choquée et horrifiée assurant les
habitants de hong kong convient de voir
un instant que la grande bretagne doit
rendre à la chine en 77 que londres
veillerai à leur assurer un avenir sûr
enfin déclarations du ministre des
affaires étrangères français monsieur
roland dumas la répression qui vient de
s'abattre sur les manifestants est une
voie sans issue
monsieur dumas suis consterné par la
répression sanglante qui vient de
s'abattre à pékin sur une foule de
manifestants désarmés
on a utilisé la force brutale pour
arrêter ou freiner la poussée
grandissante des idéaux de liberté
c'est une action qui va à l'évidence
contre le cours de l'histoire
cela nous amène a condamné l' usage de
la violence par les autorités les
chaînes de chinoise et surtout a
souhaité que celle ci abandonne cette
voix qui se révélera sans issue
réflexion maintenant d'un spécialiste de
la chine monsieur françois godement la
décision politique visiblement avait été
prise d'intervenir de faire intervenir
l'armée mais avait-elle été prise pour
qu'elle intervienne dans ces conditions
dramatiques
écoutez pour qu'un état qui se veut une
république populaire
tir sur le peuple sur la place la plus
symbolique de son histoire et devant les
caméras de la télévision mondiale
il faut un enchaînement de circonstances
il faut une décision et je dirais qu
ensuite dans l'exécution il ya un
dérapage
l'enchaînement circonstances on parle du
mouvement étudiant mais ce à quoi s'est
heurté le régime ces jours derniers
malgré l'usure qu'il escomptait c'est à
la solidarité de la population
la première reprise pacifique de la
place vendredi soir s'est heurté à un
million de personnes alors l'engrenage a
eu lieu et petit à petit cette armée
rouge dont l'indiscipliné tant vanté par
ailleurs se met à se comporter çà et là
on la prend un petit peu comme la
soldatesque des seigneurs de la guerre
avant 1949
cela c'est un signe je crois de
décomposition malgré la façade d'unité
politique qui apparaît aujourd'hui alors
conséquences à court et à moyen terme de
ce qui vient de se passer les dirigeants
au pouvoir les anciens qui se réfugient
derrière une action comme celle là est
ce que il y a aussi peut-être des choses
qui vont se passer dans le domaine
économique est ce que la chine va se
retirer derrière ses frontières coûté à
court terme d'abord les armes sont d'un
seul côté
quelle que soit l'intensité de la
protestation nous allons voir en chine
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas les moyens
d'abattre le régime physiquement celui
ci va donc survivre
par contre je crois que l'engrenage que
je viens de citer s'applique également
au reste de sa politique il n'a plus de
discours il n'a plus de programme a
présenté il n'a pas pris de décision
politique depuis quelques jours outre
que cette intervention
les anciens désormais rallié atteignent
accuse la réforme l'ouverture de tous
les péchés on peut penser que la
réaction morale à l'étranger va y
contribuer aussi je crois que
provisoirement nous allons assister en
chine une espèce de petite aire
glaciaire une tentative de restauration
d'une ère staline aux maoïstes qui
malheureusement n'a plus cours dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui
merci l'iran maintenant c'est à 3 heures
du matin à téhéran qu'à été annoncée la
mort de l'ayatollah khomeini chefs
religieux et chefs d'état réel de l'iran
depuis et 10 ans décédé de complications
à la suite d'une opération nécessitait
pas une hémorragie intestinale un deuil
de 40 jours a été aussitôt décidé la
foule s'est rassemblée dans les rues de
téhéran michel mompontet il est 7 heures
du matin à la télévision iranienne
interruption soudaine des programmes
communiqué laconique
l'ayatollah ruhollah khomeini est mort
suit alors un verset du coran de dieu
nous venons vers dieu nous allons déjà
djamala le lieu de résidence de l'imam
des centaines de milliers de personnes
se sont réunies pour prier sur l'écran
de la télévision
les dernières images du père de la
révolution
tu es encore vivant c'est encore avec
nous et pour toujours salle odyssée
fidèles jusqu'au lever du jour
à
dès l'annoncé du décès connu des
dizaines de milliers de personnes se
rassemblent dans le centre de la ville
les forces de sécurité craignent un
débordement populaire elle demande aux
iraniens de rester chez eux
mais rien n'y fait surtout les
carrefours les gardiens de la révolution
islamique
harangue la foule scènes d'hystérie
collective
dans le même temps arrivée en hâte de
toutes les régions d'iran les 83 membres
de l'assemblée des experts sont venus
entendre de la bouche même du fils de
l'imam
la lecture du testament demain
l'ayatollah khomeini sera enterré les 40
jours qui suivront seront un jour de
deuil
ainsi le veut la loi islamique cette
noix qui a été jusqu'à la férocité
durant quatre-vingt neuf ans la vie de
l'imam ruhollah moussavi khomeiny
descendants du prophète
oui dans ce testament on a appris que
c'est l'actuel président de la
république islamique iranienne monsieur
kameni qui a été désigné officiellement
par l'ayatollah comme unis pour lui
succéder à la tête du pays
c'est en 1979 que l'ayatollah comini
revenu d'un long exil prenait le pouvoir
en renversant le régime impérial pour le
remplacer par une république islamique
iranienne qui au delà de ses frontières
devait mener une croisade dans le monde
entier contre l'occident une croisade
pour la victoire de laquelle tous les
moyens étaient bons y compris les prises
d'otages ou le terrorisme
patricia cost dernière du mage de l'imam
comini vivent un vieil homme qui ne
pouvait plus nourrir tout seul la
télévision iranienne avait auparavant
montré l'opération subie les derniers
moments du guide suprême de l'iran
n'auront donc pas été caché à son peuple
ainsi en a décidé le fisc comme eni
ahmat que l'on voit ici accompagné son
père à son entrée à l'hôpital comme eni
un rebelle dès le début sur cette photo
rare il a 21 ans
un regard inflexible et triste à la fois
de son enfance à souvenirs son père
assassiné par des hommes de main d'un
féodal de la région le dieu de communes
y sera d'abord un dieu de vengeance et
non pas deux par deux
il a deux obsessions ils contestent le
pouvoir absolu du chat qui t'a fait roi
lui demande-t-il
pourquoi les stups les étrangers dicter
la loi dans le pays puis comme eni
attend son heure
en consolidant son système d' influence
à travers les réseaux des principales
mosquées du pays à 60 ans seulement il
entre dans l'histoire
l'occasion un train de réformes ordonnée
par le chat la révolution blanche qui
veut précipiter dans la modernité les
paysans et les femmes l'iran
traditionnel sa folle comme enis en fait
le porte parole il est jeté en prison
ses pairs pour le libérer le nommerons
grand ayatollah mais il est banni du
pays
commence alors pour commenee la vie d'un
exilé politique en turquie d'abord où le
régime laïque l'obligé à abandonner la
vie de religieux images inédites de
l'imam en manteau et son turban 1975
kameni décide de tester sa popularité à
l'occasion des funérailles de son fils
il demande à ses fidèles de manifester
dans les grandes villes d'iran
test réussi c'est le début d'un cycle en
trois temps manifestation répression
dans le sang
funérailles quarante jours après donnant
lieu à de nouvelles manifestations à
leur tour réprimer et ainsi de suite
pendant trois ans le mouvement culminant
jusqu'à avant le départ du shah que
comme eni apprendra dans son nouvel exil
à neauphle-le-château quatre mois en
france décisif
d'où il lancera ses dernières directives
relayées par la presse internationale
qui se bousculent sous sa tente comme
eni alors ration l'occident il demande
simplement l'avènement d'une démocratie
en iran d'ailleurs dans l'avion d'air
france qui ramène triomphalement commune
y afférent se trouve avec lui de
nombreux opposants politiques de la
gauche à la droite
à ce moment-là tous unis derrière l'imam
mes premières avertissement au monde le
premier geste de comédie la visite au
cimetière de téhéran
c'est là que naît véritablement la
révolution islamique
avec plus tard son symbole la fontaine à
l'eau rougie qui représente le sang des
martyrs déjà morts ou qui vont mourir
mais pendant les premiers mois de la
révolution c'est l'euphorie
l'armée n'a pas offert de résistance des
élections libres sont annoncées des
dizaines de journaux secret les procès
expéditif des dignitaires de l'ancien
régime suivi d'exécution sommaire près
d'un millier de personnes dans les
premiers mois de la révolution une
députée et mov - les alliés de comme
lenny que le débat sur la nouvelle
constitution premières crispations il y
est dit que la tutelle religieuse
s'exercera sur tous les pouvoirs du pays
mazargues en premier ministre s'y oppose
comme eni fait diversion et envoie les
étudiants prendre en otage l'ambassade
des états unis comme eni en profite pour
consolider son pouvoir encore une fois
bani sadr premier président la
république ne restera qu'un an et demi
au pouvoir avec sa destitution c'est la
fin de l'expérience démocratique et le
début de la terreur
la chasse aux opposants commence
partisans de bani sadr mais surtout
moudjahidine du peuple responsable
d'attentats très meurtriers puis tout
citoyen un suspect douze à quinze mille
exécution en un nom comme eni en habile
politique fera en sorte qu'aucun clan
radical ou pragmatique n'émerge
véritablement et ce régime a tenu malgré
sa rigueur islamique et les privations
il a tenu principalement à cause du
nationalisme de comme eni qui a compris
qu'il ne pouvait perdurer
quand maintenant le pays en état de
crise permanente en le mobilisant contre
l'ennemi extérieur
dans une guerre contre le voisin irakien
et contre les deux grand satan les états
unis et l'urss anciens prédateurs du
pays
en mobilisant aussi l'iran contre les
mauvais musulmans ceux qui ont tiré sur
les iraniens à la mecque ou ceux qui
insultent le prophète comme salman
rushdie les déshérités seront morts par
milliers pour l'islam mais surtout pour
une certaine idée d'avenir en pur et
indépendants poursuivis sans jamais
fléchir par ce terrible vieillard nous
interrogeons maintenant les principaux
opposants au régime iranien pour savoir
ce qu'il pense de la disparition de
l'imam khomeiny au premier rang de ceux
là le fils aîné du shah d'iran reza
pahlavi qui vit actuellement aux
etats-unis depuis l'exil et la mort de
son père reza pahlavi est avec nous en
direct de washington en compagnie de
jacques à bouchard jacques oui daniel
comme vous l'avez dit je suis ici en
compagnie donc du fils du chah disparu
vous avez entendu comme moi daniel
bilalian notre présentateur annoncé que
kameni été désigné comme le successeur
de l'imam khomeiny est ce que ça veut
dire que le régime a réussi à faire
l'économie d'une guerre de succession
d'une guerre des héritiers possible de
communier je pense que l'élection de
ramener encore une fois nous prouve
l'échec total de ce régime dans le
règlement du problème de la succession
je croise tout vous expliquer pourquoi
la république islamique qui s'étaient
nettement démontré quel état basé sur la
souveraineté populaire qu'elle plutôt
basée sur la religion et que c'est à
c'est au guide
cette eau farine disons donc dans ce cas
khomeiny d'être la seule personne
autorisée à faire tous les décrets
nécessaires pour maintenir le système en
place aujourd'hui et des plus là et la
république islamique
au fait est morte en même temps que
khomeiny ce qui reste c'est un groupe de
personnalités religieuses nettement
inférieur aux autorités réel dans le
contexte des grands ayatollahs qui se
sont toujours montrées contre ce régime
est la porte ouverte aux plus forts
c'est plus fort qui risquent de gagner
je veux dire par là que khomeiny n'est
pas une personnalité crédible qui n'a
pas l'autorité religieuse ni la
légitimité de vouloir soumettre des
grands ayatollahs sous son égide
ça ne va pas tenir debout c'est comme si
vous êtes vous espériez que les
cardinals se soumettent à un simple
prêtre ou qu'un capitaine veulent
commander des généraux mal à tenir
debout majesté quel sentiment avez-vous
éprouvé en attendant en écoutant
l'annoncé de la mort de l'ayatollah
khomeiny et quelle va être votre action
maintenant est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une ouverture pour vous vous savez
c'est pas une question de réaction
envers la mort de khomeiny se cache ce à
quoi je chausse ce songe toujours c'est
mon pays et les conséquences de cette
république islamique est l'état actuel
de mon pays et delà des circonstances
politiques et bien entendu du futur
dans ce contexte à travers ce vide
politique qui est créé et suivant la
situation je suis sûr qu'on habitude on
aboutira avec un conflit entre les
factions et qui reste du régime
ça nous laisse une opportunité à
l'opposition nationaliste et
démocratique de restaurer une fois pour
toutes la souveraineté populaire dans
notre pays et dans ce contexte
ceci fait l'objet de ma mission
personnelle et ma responsabilité envers
mes compatriotes
mais est-ce que c'est notre chance
est-ce que vous avez la moindre chance
de remonter sur le trône
ça c'est une question qui devrait être
décidé par le peuple iranien
une fois libéré est libre de faire son
choix pour le futur et ceci ne peut se
faire que dans le contexte d'une
restauration de la souveraineté
populaire et je crois formellement que
la monarchie constitutionnelle reste en
iran l'alternative la plus crédible mais
je vous dis c'est pas la question
d'imposer une solution aux iraniens à
présent c'est une question de les
laisser de leur laisser le choix du
futur et c'est là le but de notre
mission majesté je vous remercie
parmi les opposants au régime de
l'ayatollah comics dont certains furent
ses premiers compagnons de route
d'ailleurs la plupart sont réfugiés en
france voici leurs réactions et leurs
impressions sur l'avenir nous en avons
retenu trois monsieur chapour bakhtiar
dernier chef de gouvernement du shah
d'iran monsieur lazhar irresponsable des
moudjahidine du peuple principale
composante de l'opposition au régime de
téhéran
enfin monsieur bani sadr premier
président de la république islamique
iranienne
personne ne remplace vraiment commune y
étant donnée son impact personnel et son
passé et un certain charisme qu'il avoue
au début de son règne si je peux dire
ans qui aimait mais ce qui est
absolument sûr à mon sens c'est que il y
aura des heures et il y aura des
bagarres entre les différentes factions
des dés ou là où vous sentez vous
soulager votre tête avait été mise à
prix par khomeiny seul un feu ce n'est
pas d'une importance capitale c'est le
cas je le dis sans jouer sur les mots
mais je dois vous dire que quand je
regarde
tant de malheurs en iran je ne peux pas
dire que je fais abstraction de ce qui
était mon sentiment profond dans un
soupir de soulagement
non pas pour moi mais pour ceux qui ont
souffert et qui souffre et qui sont
prendre du tout les jours à des
prétextes futiles absurde et parfois
souvent mensongère la mort du dictateur
le plus d'insectes du monde contemporain
ne peut que susciter félicitations pour
l'ensemble du peuple iranien parce que
cela annonce le début de l'ère de la
liberté pour l'iran la liberté ne va pas
s'instaurer atterrant automatiquement
il faudrait des moyens et il n'y a que
l'alternative démocratique de khomeiny
c'est à dire le conseil national de la
résistance iranienne
présidée par monsieur radio j qui est
capable de le renverser par le moyen de
l'armée de libération nationale
iranienne et le morcellement c'est la
mort de la dictature
on savait que même aucune aucun autre
dictateur dans le monde n'est pas mort
comme aimant khomeiny il est mort
vraiment dans la passe même il n'a plus
les successeurs niveau vous croyez qu
après la disparition de l'imam khomeiny
les mollahs n'ont plus d'emprise sur
l'iran je suis heureux et je suis sûr
qu'elles garderont pour mouvement est
lent on ne peut pas dire non
mais ils perdront avec une grande
vitesse leur mainmise sur une toute
dernière réaction extérieure celle là
celle du pape jean paul ii qui estime
que la mort d'un homme mérite le respect
et la réflexion cette réflexion doit
porter dit il sur ce qu'il a fait dans
son pays et dans une partie importante
du monde une déclaration qui peut
intriguer
voilà tous les éléments dont nous
disposons ce soir je vous disais tout à
l'heure que monsieur khamenei l'actuel
président de la république islamique
iranienne avait été désigné pour
succéder à l'ayatollah comédie est ce
qu'on peut dire ce soir bernadette
benyamine que cette désignation règle
tous les problèmes de succession en iran
vous savez des liens je crois que le
seul fait d'avoir désigné ali khamenei
comme successeur prouve précisément que
rien n'est réglé en iran
l'assemblée des experts qui vient de
prendre ces décisions avait en fait le
choix essentiellement entre deux hommes
ahmad le fils de l'ayatollah khomeiny et
surtout le président du parlement
iranien hachémi rafsandjani
tous deux avaient des titres divers cd
contesté au sein du pouvoir à téhéran où
il avait des amis fidèles comme des
ennemis irréductibles le fait donc ali
khamenei était et choisit tend à faire
penser que les 70 experts ne sont pas
parvenus à se mettre d'accord et qu'en
désespoir de cause ils se sont rabattus
sur cet homme que nous voyons sur ces
images
l'actuel président de la république un
homme sans réelle envergure en fait une
solution de transition qui pourrait
favoriser hachémi rafsandjani qui est un
peu son maître à penser
mais au-delà de cette nomination il faut
bien voir que c'est un pays isolé aux
combles des difficultés économiques
souffrent de graves dissensions internes
qui se retrouvent ce soir sans grand
leader pour le faire avancer
l'ère du père fondateur est terminée
le successeur désigné ni les autres
prétendants n'ont pas la dimension
intellectuelle religieuse ni morale que
posséder l'ayatollah khomeini après dix
ans de terreur
c'est une nouvelle page de l'histoire de
l'iran qui commence ce soir une page
dont le premier mot pourrait être
désarroi l'actualité de ce dimanche
c'est encore un drame une catastrophe
ferroviaire en urss dans la région de
l'oural précisément à l'origine
l'explosion d'un gazoduc à proximité
d'une voie ferrée sur laquelle se
croisaient à cet instant même deux
trains en portant des enfants vers des
colonies de vacances un chiffre a été
avancé 800 disparus à cet or si nous ne
disposons que de quelques images des
secours aux blessés thiery calmette des
enfants gravement brûlé soignés à même
la piste de l'aéroport ils viennent
enfin d'être évacué de ouf à l'endroit
de la terrible catastrophe 200 morts 800
disparus des centaines de blessés et ce
n'est qu'un bilan provisoire
la nuit dernière vers 23h15 deux trains
se croisent dans les monts de l'oural à
400 km de moscou
les deux convois transportent environ 12
cents passagers en tout en majorité des
enfants qui partent en vacances
c'est probablement le passage simultané
des deux trains qui a déclenché
l'explosion une explosion causée par une
fuite de gaz liquide s'échappant d'un
gazoduc qui longe les voies à cet
endroit
messieurs gorbatchev s'est rendu sur
place tout à l'heure accompagnée par
plusieurs de ses ministres
voici les premières images qui nous
parviennent en ce moment sur la plus
grande catastrophe ferroviaire qu'ait
connue le rss
une tornade de feu voilà la description
des témoins de l'accident
un choc terrible une dizaine de wagons
détruits et puis la panique en pleine
nuit un orage empêché l'évacuation des
premières victimes
les dons de sang affluent de toutes les
régions du pays car c'est le sens qui
fait le plus défaut en ce moment la
ville d'ajka à 15 km de là s'est
retrouvée transformée en hôpital de
campagne et monsieur gorbatchev et aller
la visiter
à paris le président mitterrand a
exprimé son émotion à sa sympathie au
numéro un soviétique pendant que le
ministre des affaires étrangères roland
dumas proposé à l'urss si nécessaire
tous les moyens de secours dans la
france dispose en ce moment les
recherches se poursuivent pour retrouver
toutes les victimes parce que jusqu'à
présent 400 d'entre elles à peine ont
été retrouvés les polonais ont voté
aujourd'hui pour le premier tour des
élections au sénat et à la diète le
parlement polonais premières élections
semi démocratique depuis l'instauration
du communisme après la deuxième guerre
mondiale semi démocratique dans la
mesure où les deux tiers des sièges sont
encore réservées aux membres du parti de
varsovie jacques merlino toxiques a
depuis 40 ans on n'avait jamais connu
une telle affluence dans les bureaux de
vote que ce soit en ville ou à la
campagne
les polonais ont tenu aujourd'hui à
marquer en masse leur intérêt pour ces
élections exceptionnel
à 11 heures il ya wissant qui sont venus
sur 2600 habitants de ces villages
autres un groupe c'est plus que les
autres fois c'est très beau coup 1
devant les isoloirs les files d'attentes
étaient souvent longue mais l'ambiance
extrêmement calme et détendue chacun
était venu avec son petit matériel stylo
lunettes ou loupé de manière à pouvoir
rayer avec précision les noms des
candidats dont on ne voulait pas un
système complexe ce qui nécessitait 5 à
10 minutes pour remplir un bulletin de
vote
chaque électeur devant rayé au moins 80
non la veille à la télévision les
cheveux les uns avaient appelé à la
patience soulignant que ce n'était
qu'une première ouverture démocratique
et qu'il restait du chemin à faire
auparavant le général josé ce qui avait
tenu un discours très modéré se plaçant
au dessus de la mêlée mais affirmant
avec les doutes et l'appartenance de la
pologne au camp socialiste
les bureaux de vote fermeront tard ce
soir 10 heures pour l'ensemble de la
pologne
il faudra sans doute attendre le milieu
de la journée de demain pour avoir les
premiers résultats ce n'est qu'alors que
l'on sera ce le dernier sondage avait vu
juste ils donnaient environ 60% à
solidarnosc et moins de 10 % au parti
communiste
la 5e conférence mondiale sur le sida
s'est ouverte aujourd'hui à montréal au
canada avec cette déclaration terrible
d'un représentant africain d'où la
maladie est originaire je le cite en
afrique centrale
la propagation du sida est comparable à
la vitesse d'un feu de forêt sur les
cent mille décès dus au sida dans le
monde près de 25000 concerne d afrique
si rien ne vient endiguer cette maladie
ce sont des pays entiers d'afrique de ce
continent dont qui risque de disparaître
l'exemple eh bien nous sommes allés le
chercher dans l'une de ces nations
menacé au coeur du mal dans un village
de tanzanie en quête d'un gainsbourg g
et philippe montoise y cet enfant va
mourir son teint
a dû le porter ainsi pendant trois
heures car on vient de loin et afia qui
garent à mal le seul dispensaire de la
région aucun médecin
juste trois infirmiers à peine quelques
aspirine
dérisoire face à un petit garçon atteint
du sida déjà inconscient pourtant il a
fallu la présence de la caméra et notre
insistance pour que cet enfant ne soit
pas renvoyé chez lui
la firme hier avaient diagnostiqué une
indigestion
le lendemain jason ne s'est pas réveillé
il avait 12 ans un drame ordinaire dans
cette région du nord de la tanzanie
ici où le lac victoria s'étend vers
l'ouganda c'est tout un peuple qui
certains cas chénier village frontière
le sida il fait des ravages
un mort tous les dix jours la maladie a
déjà emporté une centaine d'adultes sur
les mille habitants que comptait le
village orphelins les enfants se
regroupent entre frères et soeurs entre
voisins des enfants parfois veiller
parent grand-parent les gars rester
seuls avec leur mort partout les tombes
s'aligner derrière les maisons
cette vieille femme s'occupe seule de
ses 16 petits enfants
les quatre fils sont morts et après
leurs femmes tous le sida en fait une
catastrophe dont le sort est morte qui
veillera sur les enfants
le sida frappe toute la population
hommes et femmes en âge d'activité
sexuelle contamination d'autant plus
facile que la polygamie est très
répandue dans cette famille il n'y a
plus d'homme
ce bébé élevé par sa grand-mère
orphelins aussi de maison plus loin à
bella 20 ans déjà évident sur sa peau
les traces du sida je vivais dans un
autre village avec mon mari
il y a deux mois on est tombés malades
alors on est retournés chacun dans notre
famille ici je suis mieux c'est ma grand
mère qui s'occupe de moi à bella était
sans doute séropositif depuis longtemps
tout comme ce bébé
il a deux ans et demi ses parents sont
morts il ya deux ans du sida au village
ils sont aujourd'hui 270 orphelins
livrés à eux mêmes comment vont-ils
grandir alors qu'il faut d'abord
simplement apprendre à survivre survivre
en travaillant les plus grands vont aux
champs qu'on cultive pommes de terre
manioc et banane les plus jeunes ont
encore parfois la chance d'aller à
l'école
70 colis pour un seul mètre ce qui
manque est essentiel des cailloux et des
bancs pour tout le monde
le chef du village alerté les autorités
sur le problème du sida et des orphelins
sans résultat nous sommes actuellement
aidé par l'église pour informer les gens
on leur dit d'arrêter les échanges
partenaires on prône la fidélité dans le
mariage
un homme doit avoir une seule femme nous
avons vraiment besoin d' aide pour tous
ces orphelins qui n'ont plus rien de
l'aide n'est pas n'importe laquelle car
au mois de janvier l'unique épicerie de
cash aigner a reçu un stock de
préservatifs expédier des états unis
préservatif que le pasteur le chef du
village ont aussitôt confisquer les
distribuer serait offense et coutumes et
religions entêtement rigueur morale
inadaptée à une telle urgence en outre
le premier hôpital de la région est à 60
kilomètres de là il faut sept heures de
très mauvaises routes pour y arriver
doolaeghe et seulement cinq médecins
pour 220 lits mais on veut donner
l'exemple
le test de dépistage du sida et
systématique avant chaque transfusion
les chiffres terrifiants un patient sur
deux est séropositif il faut maintenant
éviter que d'autres enfants comme celui
ci soit accidentellement contaminés par
injection pour lui sa mère c'est qu'il
est trop tard
absolument pas
donc les gens sont de toute façon
condamnée à court terme bien parce qu'on
dit est considéré comme un moyen de
prévention de voir le gouvernement et il
emploie des le canapé ce qu'on appelle
économe la papatte arrivent et disent
avoir étalé au gouvernement mais moi je
travaille dans un habitat des d'église
comme ça nous nous n'encourageons pas
seulement aidé de se protéger
nous encourageons quittons le change de
cause les changements de comportement
cet homme à 34 ans atteint du sida
il est venu pour qu'on l'aide à mourir
symbole en tanzanie un peu plus
disparaît dans cette vallée du rift qui
fut il ya trois millions d'années le
berceau de l'humanité
actualité terrible que celle de ce
dimanche respirons un instant avec le
sport le tennis roland garros
la journée de toutes les surprises
l'élimination de plusieurs favoris
l'america agassi l'argentine gabriela
sabatini mais aussi des fêtes de thierry
tulasne dernier français en compétition
face à l'américain bergen à roland
garros nous rejoignons tout de suite
jean mamère genre oui effectivement
daniel jugé qu il était trop fatigué
thierry tulasne faut remuer courbatu il
avait les jambes lourdes
il a effectivement trop jouer entre les
simples en cinq sets et les doubles
interminable avec jérôme potier ce n'est
pas sans résistance que thierry tulasne
est tombé il a pris un set là derrière
mais le marathonien l'homme en grande
santé c'était cet après-midi père guerre
je dirais que cet homme a éliminé le
dernier français à roland garros heureux
jim courier heureux de la surprise qu'il
causait la performance qu'ils réalisent
en éliminant andre agassi
andre agassi qui sur son service dans le
quatrième set a montré ses limites de
concentration et de volonté de gagner
andre agassi la révélation du temps à 88
a trouvé son maître
tim courrier le nouveau venu de l'école
américaine
elle sort en premier gabriela sabatini
mais la tête basse maria jose fernandez
pudique reste un pas derrière sans doute
encore sous le coup de l'émotion
il est vrai qu'au concours de pronostics
peu de monde miser sur sa victoire
ferland dès ce soir est au paradis
sabatini elle est en fait alors daniel
je vous propose de nous reprendre tout
de suite maintenant sur le central où se
termine un match un match entre nancy ni
hell avec mon signe que vous découvrez
sur votre écran et c'est un argentin
il est tête de série numéro 11 est
classé numéro 13 mondiale et jakob
hlasek tête de série numéro 6 nuls en 8
mondial les deux hommes en sont au
cinquième set
manzini sert pour le match et il mène en
ce moment 30-15 mans s'ils n'y avaient
remporté les deux premiers sets 6-4 6-4
et perdu les deux suivantes 6 4 6 2 un
truc est particulièrement intense au
moment au mans signe sa première balle
de match à risque depuis voilà depuis le
5 juin maintenant pas un joueur n'a pris
son service alors que van signalé fait
le break d'entrée dans ce cinquième set
l'entv qui revient de loin parce qu'il
était vraiment un magazine ils sont fin
de quatrième set il s'est bien retrouvé
dans le cinquième et finalement il a
maintenant deux balles de match pour lui
ment cynique qui rencontreraient edberg
et berki cet après midi a aisément
vaincu le yougoslave izany et vic
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour vous
annoncer la victoire de becker également
contre l'argentin perd alors là d'une
victoire difficile de becker en cinq
sets il a même eu une balle de match
contre lui ment c'est milan qui rate son
premier service
le central est vraiment
il a gagné 26 mitterrand prend encore de
l'île à berne
alors il y avait aussi deux autres
victoires à noter chez les dames après
là je dirais la surprenante défaite de
servette unis il ya eu la victoire de
sanchez tête de série numéro sept et la
victoire de novotna tête de série numéro
11 c'est logique la hiérarchie a été
respectée après chez les féminines donc
sous vos yeux
victoire de man city alors on se
retrouve demain avec notamment un très
beau match pour lendl il y aura
contre-champ ça va être très joli
voilà vous n'avez rien oublié jean merci
on a les résultats du tiercé maintenant
ça c'est pas en direct en léger différé
vous allez voir les résultats
s'affichent et sur votre écran pour
gagner il fallait jouer
las le 14 et le 4 et pour ce qui
concerne le quarté + et bien ajouter le
5 et vous gagnez un peu plus de 24000
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après bien entendu les prévisions
météo avec josé blanc lapierre dernier
journal aux alentours de zéro heure avec
philippe gassot demain matin rendez vous
avec télé matin à 6h prendre très
exactement
et puis demain soir ici même à 20h vous
retrouverez et avec l'autre je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne et je vous dis à samedi prochain
bonsoir